the Supreme Court of the United States
that's the big court that does all the
stuff they have reversed the affirmative
action clause in essence that allowed uh
colleges and universities to
discriminate based on race so let's just
get to that this is on the Fly we're
getting info real quick on this so let's
get to that real quick and then we'll
get to the rest of the show today that
we had planned for you this is from NBC
the Supreme Court issued a six to three
divided ruling on a pair of challenges
to affirmative action policies at
Harvard and the University of North
Carolina with potential implications
across higher education and Beyond the
Court ruled against the program saying
the majority of saying in the majority
opinion that the systems in place lack
sufficiently focused and measurable
objectives warranting the use of race
unavoidably employee race in a negative
manner involve racial stereotyping and
lack meaningful endpoints those
admission programs cannot be reconciled
with the guarantees of the equal
protection Clause but the court did not
rule out race entirely in admission
programs adding nothing prohibits
universities from considering an
applicant's discussion of how race
affected the applicant's life so long as
the discussion is concretely tied to a
quality of character or unique ability
that the particular applicant can
contribute to the university so let's
just be very very clear on this
first off again this is really great we
are we are reversing we are eliminating
systemic racism right so the left and
the progressives and the Democrats and
all the lunatics that are on MSNBC right
now screaming about this and the view
which is on right now and I'm of no
doubt that they're all going
particularly batshit right now they love
systemic racism that they're somehow
systemic racism in the system that the
system is built in a way that allows
racism now it really didn't exist except
as I have said many times over the last
couple years one of the last places that
systemic racism existed not just racism
people are racist you're going to find
racists here and there individual
racists are going to make individual
choices and that's just part of the
human condition and you'd have to kill
an awful lot of people if you want to
get rid of that the best thing you can
do is teach people why racism and
collectivism is bad but but basically
the last place that systemic racism
existed in America was College
admissions and what was happening uh was
that at places like Harvard they were
discriminating particularly against
Asian students because they wanted for
whatever reason because because leftists
view the world through a racial prism
they wanted more black students so the
average person might go oh they want to
help black students and that's very nice
but of course by helping somebody you
have to punish somebody else and I'm not
for punishing anyone based on race I
don't think that an Asian kid whether
he's a third generation let's say his
grandparents came from China and
probably came with nothing and busted
their butts and cared about education
and family and hard work and everything
else or whether he's a second generation
or first generation immigrant from South
Korea let's say and the parents owned a
bodega and busted their ass and all of
those things and they do it all right I
don't think they should be discriminated
against anywhere and the Supreme Court
of the United States agrees so what we
are now going to see over the next
couple days in weeks is the Hysteria
that the left offers with basically
everything but they will not have
arguments against this because there is
no good argument for discrimination